come on everyone needs a good laugh yeah
the makeup might have been a mistake but
I've gone to the trouble to do it so I'm
heck I'm sticking with it so yeah it's
April Fool's and I can't do anything
serious because no one will believe that
I am in fact being serious about it so
I'm gonna do something stupid and silly
and ridiculous
so yeah it's been mentioned in response
to a couple of videos that I have a bit
of a joker
esque laughs you know what I'm gonna
roll with that and I'm gonna demonstrate
for you folks basically ten laugh
variants these are not intended to be
specific impressions of any given Joker
up to this point this is just me having
a bit of fun so why don't we kick things
off with a good low chuckle that's
always sort of a good one and you can
build out of that into something else
what else we got okay how about a nice
good out of breath there's the sudden
outburst we have what I think of as the
tickled hooting there's the high giggle
you gotta have a sarcastic laugh
[Laughter]
there's failed restraint we've got the
hard cackle we got what I tend to think
of as the resigned laughter this would
be the sort of thing that you'd have
like when you know you're defeated but
you got a laugh anyway and then you know
sometimes you just gotta bring it all
together for a bit of total madness
[Laughter]
there you go
whether I just made you laugh whether I
just give you nightmares
hope you have a good April first I would
say have a good April Fool's Day but
honestly it's had I hate it Fool's Day I
think it's terrible I think the people
who genuinely try to prank people tend
to be asses I'm not gonna make a blanket
statement but I'll call it a trend have
a decent day in any case and I can try
and get this crap off my face well I
figure out how the heck to do that you
can check out a whole bunch of stuff if
you wanna god what is anyone still
around would you want to sponsor
somebody who looks like this well if you
do
patreon down there plus you know merch
links social media blah blah blah it's
all down there have a look don't don't
worry about it
because at the end of the day you're all
the council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]